welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the man of
spoils and this video we're breaking
down the movie that kick-started the DC
EU that is Man of Steel in my opinion
it's the best Superman movie ever made
and I think that the film is massively
underrated throughout this video we're
going to be going through the best
Easter eggs in the film that I
definitely think will make you
appreciate the movie more obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
the movie yet then I highly recommend
that you check out now please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy the video and
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
for content like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this and let's get into our breakdown of
Man of Steel ok so the movie opens with
the Warner Brothers and DC logos in the
form of Kryptonian metal not only does
this play into the idea of Krypton's
aesthetic and style but it also subtly
lets us know that biggest downfall
throughout this introduction we learn
that the people of the planet mind too
much and this eventually caused it to
implode the metal can be seen laced
throughout all of their technology from
their armor to their ships holograms and
communication devices clearly they
became so reliant on this metal that
they completely harvested the planets
core of the resource and this eventually
led to the death of their world though
it's never said in the movie just
looking at the way that things are
designed it's clearly been chosen as a
reason for why Krypton fell apart and
shows just how much the creative team
were thinking into this a snake this is
murdered in the name of the film itself
and how it ties into Superman originally
Krypton was thought of as an ice planet
however Snyder and Co thought long and
hard about why the character would be
known as the Man of Steel and how this
would tie into his origin thus they
coupled together the characters
long-established nickname his home and
how the planet ended up destroying
itself so Man of Steel symbolically ties
to metal which ties back to Krypton and
how the planet was destroyed so yeah
lots of things going on in the subtext
of the film and after the opening we
witnessed the birth of kal-el
accompanying the score by Hans Zimmer
the first real son that we hear is Cal's
heartbeat and symbolically this shows
that Superman is the heart of the DC
Universe his birth also mirrors his
death in many ways and the positioning
of the shot and the scene was purposely
chosen by Snyder to show the beginning
and end of his life though he was
resurrected in Justice League this is an
astounding use of cinematography and is
definitely a credit to just how good
Snyder is able to visualize things
jor-el visits the council and is pleased
fall on deaf ears the way this scene is
shot also echoes Lara's death and is
purposely repeated to show that the
downfall of Krypton lies solely with the
politicians another notable aspect is
that she's killed by fire and Batman V
Superman Lex Ponder's what to do with a
witch and then he suggests that by fire
had Martha been killed in the movie she
would have been burned alive showing the
mirroring of his two mothers Zod arrives
with his forces and he may know is that
one of them is a giant compared to the
rest this is actually a character called
Namek he is this size because the
character actually fused his biology
with the rondo beast that we see in the
opening of the movie in order to give
himself larger muscles and physical
prowess jor-el is escorted away by Zod's
forces but he manages to gain the upper
hand with help from key Lex helix is
actually a reference their robotic butt
leather
jor-el had in the comics and it's a nice
little nod to the source material jor-el
goes and gets the Codex and in order to
do this he has to dive into water and
swim for it this is paralleled in Batman
V Superman when a diver does the same
thing in order to grab the massive
kryptonite rock upon escaping we see
jor-el flying through the sky on a
dragon-like beast
during this in the sky line you can spot
a moon that's been torn apart it is
watch along snyder reveal that this was
caused by an ancient version of doomsday
this is why when Lex goes to
resurrecting bbs it comes with a warning
as doomsday has the ability to
completely destroy worlds should he
become powerful enough
Clark was able to kill him but it could
have been much worse had he not
sacrificed himself speaking of doomsday
the ensuing fight that jor-el has
against Zod
also mirrors the one that Clark has with
doomsday in several ways the way things
are shot as well as the Empire
all line up perfectly and yeah you know
what give Schneider his roses Doral is
able to go hand to hand with sod quite
easily and know he was a scientist he is
clearly a well-equipped fighter we
learned in the movie that at Birth
Kryptonians are taller they have to fit
a certain element of society and they
must do this without question the fact
that Jarell can fight shows that he
likely disobeyed the role set out for
him by the Council of Krypton and
decided to go beyond his predetermined
path sods face is cut during the scene
and this scar can also be seen on
Doomsday's face in the following film
showing that the two are one in the same
the codec is placed into kal-el and it
contains all of the information for life
on Krypton in Snyder's original five
plan film for the DC EU this was going
to be taken by dockside and then turned
into the anti-life equation which would
allow him to create the nightmare
version of earth that we see in Bruce's
vision Clarke lands on earth and we jump
forward several decades to see him
rescuing people trapped on an oil rig
cavil was asked to shave his chest for
the scene
however he cited the death of Superman
as a reason not to as he's sporting
hairy pecks under the suit Clarke lands
in the water and we cut back and forth
between his memories as a child we see
his senses overwhelm him and he flees to
a cupboard to block everything out his
mother arrives and tells him to listen
to her voice and in the series he always
has an ear on her and Lois this is how
he's able to rescue Lois as she's
dropped off a skyscraper and BBS in the
live stream Schneider did say that he'd
heard about the you either
Aquaman rescued him at this point
however he did not confirm it he said
that it would be a cool idea though so
draw your own conclusions from that and
if you want Aquaman to rescue him then
go with that by all means now Clark
makes his way to land and sees his
school bus which reminds him of the time
he saved his class one of the students
is Pete Ross who had actually become a
friend of Clark in the comics and Lana
Lang who was of course his first love
there's also a nod to Chloe Sullivan in
the movie at one point with his sign in
the background of a scene but yeah
probably not best to mention her for a
long time because
um Amy Adams also appeared in Smallville
too so there are a lot of little tie
backs to the show it's here that were
introduced to Jonathan Kent and I love
how both Clark's fathers are played by
people who've also played Robin Hood not
sheriff that's an easter egg but here it
is in the list Clark eventually makes
its way to a military base after making
a guy's truck look like a game of
kerplunk and here he meets Lois Clark
helps her with her bags and she says be
careful the heavy but we can clearly see
him lifting them with ease he journeys
to the ship and on there sees a pod with
its lid open showing that someone from
it climbed out Snyder said that this was
supposed to be a nod to Supergirl who is
already meant to be on earth and could
end up appearing in a DC film very soon
after powering up the ship
Clark is introduced to a hologram of his
father who recounts the history of
Krypton in the scene we can also see
clocks vessel traveling to earth behind
it is the star symbol and this is a
reference to the Christopher Reeve movie
in which the ship looked very similar
Clark is given his suit and he gets the
blue and red one over the black that is
typical of his house in the watch along
Snyder referred to this as the Sioux
optimism and this represents a more
hopeful version of his family Clark
takes his first flight and I absolutely
love this scene as it really feels like
he's just having a blast with it we
learn about the death of Jonathan and
Lois also discovers who years quark
returns home and we can see a LexCorp
van dropping him off I'm not sure if I'm
reaching here but in Batman V Superman
we learned that Lex is well aware of
who's Superman really is it's also clear
that he's been keeping tabs on other
metahumans that due to the files on his
computer so he may have had someone in
his company following clock in order to
keep tabs on him again and that might be
a reach but it's just a fan theory I've
come up with in my head to show how Lex
knows where clock lives and who years
Zod puts out a call for the Kryptonian
and this is intercepted by the army
namely general Swanwick in the Snyder
cut Swanwick is going to be Martian
Manhunter and it's rumored that
additional scenes are being filmed with
this reveal this message from Zod is
clearly worrying for Clark and he
travels to a church seeking advice the
priest actually returns in Batman V
Superman as the
one that carries out clocks funeral and
it's a nice little return for the
character to be on both sides of his
sacrifices Jesus can also be seen behind
clock as he questions whether he should
give up his life for Humanity the
stained glass imagery is also meant to
echo this as Jesus in this scene does
the same thing to God which this image
portrays there's more Jesus imagery in
the film such as Clarke throwing his
arms out when he exits dodge ship which
looks very similar to a crucifixion pose
Jesus was crucified at 33 which we learn
as the age that clock is in the film
Jesus was also stabbed with a spear
which would later be called the spear of
destiny so we have this notion of Spears
being used to damage gods in Batman V
Superman Batman uses a spear with
kryptonite on it because Snyder said
that he would view this as a weapon
worthy of taking down a god Supes goes
to the military and this shot echoes the
media attention in Batman V Superman
this shows that guns on the only weapons
we have and that it is possible to take
people down in other ways BVS centers
around Lex defaming Supes and his court
appearance to mirrors him being taken in
by the military showing the correlation
between these two moments quark hands
himself over to the Kryptonians and
though they never say kneel before Zod
the effects he feels on the ship force
him to do it it's here that he
experiences visions of Zod's plan and at
one point he sinks into a pit of skulls
this is reference once more in the day
of the dead scene in Batman V Superman
in this stream Snyder also addressed
this moment and said that the skull
symbolized Superman's worst fear is not
his own death but rather the death of
all those around him we also see a
destroyed moon perhaps referencing the
one from the beginning Louis manages to
disable the atmosphere on the ship
through bringing a sort of computer
virus aboard it in the form of jor-el we
actually find out that he designed the
ship so clearly the guy was a great
scientist that helped to build vessels
this also explains how he was able to
create such a good ship to send his son
off with quark battles the Kryptonian
forces in Smallville and we see several
notable locations firstly we see a sign
that shows the name of the local team
that is the Smallville Spartans which is
a reference to Snyder's prior film 300
the locals also hide in the
stuffy's which is called Ezra's mail
Depot as her a small actually found it's
small bill so this is a nod to the
town's creator we also see the local
Sears destroyed in the battle and in the
film we learned that Martha works there
however in BBS she works in a diner and
likely had to change her job because it
was destroyed during the fight the
Kryptonians discovered that kal-el has
the Codex within him and Schneider did
him that this opens things up for the
future
he's cited that it's possible for Clarke
to potentially restart the Kryptonian
race if DC ever want to he also teased
that Faora could come back and try and
extract this actually hope they do a
Supergirl movie that she's the villain
in because yeah one of the best
characters in this movie and I'd love to
see the two go head-to-head they
launched the world engine which impacts
the Indian Ocean and this location would
of course return for Batman V Superman
one also goes to Metropolis where the
terraforming commences in the ocean
clock stops the one on his side and he's
badly wounded he reaches out of the Sun
and this actually recharges him this is
an element from the comics as Superman
draws his power from the Sun however it
was also brought up in Batman V Superman
after the nuke attack now I just want to
give a huge shout out to Daniel edits
whose place the metropolis scene side by
side with the one from Batman V Superman
it shows just how much effort the
creative team really put into making
sure things lined up as side by side
everything is absolutely perfect I
really can't stress enough how to Welli
scenes accompany one another and it's
incredible seeing the battle from the
perspective of Clark and then Bruce in
the sequel you can honestly see why
Bruce would become so terrified of
Superman to the point that he would try
and destroy him and though Man of Steel
often gets criticized for the
destruction in the scene I feel like it
was necessary to set up the following
film Snyder actually addressed this
controversy and his watch along and said
that this was an invasion movie and that
we needed to see the real-life
consequences of terraforming and just
how powerful the Kryptonians really were
this destruction led into why Clark had
to snap his neck which I'll get into in
just a bit now on point they go through
a building and
a split-second you can see a poster that
says keep calm and called Batman this is
actually referenced in the following
movie as we see things from the point of
view of Jack we learn Jack as a Wayne
employee that keeps calm in the
destruction and calls Bruce or rather
Batman so he did keep calm and called
Batman there's also a Lex Corp truck
which sidekicks a clock and for a split
second we can see the smiley face symbol
from Watchmen Snyder of course tower
erected Watchmen so this is another call
back to his work at one point they also
go to a construction site and we can see
a sign that says 106 days without an
accident this changes to zero days
without an accident after Clark is
smashed into it there's a building that
has a blaze Comics sign on it which is a
fictional comic book company in the DC
Universe we also see Utopia casinos
which is owned by Tony Gallo who
discovered Superman's weakness was
kryptonite the building doesn't get
destroyed which is also a nice nod to
the character this is also a Wayne
enterprise satellite that I'm sure you
noticed but hey we like to be thorough
the battle ends with Superman snapping
Zod's neck and those Snyder has received
a lot of criticism over this in the live
stream he said that now we can debate
over whether you would do this not
symbolically it shows that Clark has a
choice to either be with his own people
or humanity but he chooses us and the
family of Earth rather than his own
now I don't know if this is the definite
but I think this train station might
also be where Bruce ends up taking
clock-in BBS also there's a little
Riddler symbol there and BBS which
forgot to point out on my last breakdown
now the movie ends with Jonathan seeing
a vision of Clark as the man he would
become and Clark joins the Daily Planet
as a reporter Lois says welcome to the
planet because she's saying welcome to
the planet look look you're not stupid
you got it I love you now that pretty
much ends the movie and sets up things
to come leading into a DC you that I
personally love now obviously I loved
you your thoughts on the video and if
there's anything we missed
comment below and let us know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown of
spider-man homecoming which is gonna be
linked at the end you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you massively appreciate it and
there's a thank you you get access to
content early you want to come chat to
us after the show either follow us that
heavy spoilers or click the discord link
in the description below those are the
best ways to keep it a date with the
channel so hopefully we see over there
very soon
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]